- I have to ask this
because I didn't know that
you had like a bagpipe phase.
- Oh my God.
Our family's got,
- [Kelly] Which is awesome.
- our family has Scottish roots.
- [Kelly] Okay,
- And I always-
- But a lot of people have Scottish roots
that don't play the bagpipe.
- Yes.
(Kelly laughs)
But I really love the sound of bagpipes.
- [Kelly] It's beautiful.
- And I got it on a consignment, you know?
Thrifts, or whatever you call that,
the sheet when you get used
stuff, you know, the newspaper?
Remember those?
(Kelly laughing)
- I do.
- [Bonnie] And it was for sale
and I bought 'em.
And I asked in my college paper,
I advertised in the Want ads
for anybody that knew how to blow.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
And then it said like this,
"Bagpipes." underneath,
and that was my ad.
- Oh my God.
I was like, what kind of
results happened after?
- And then I get, I said,
"Know how to blow bagpipes,
freshman wants to learn."
But my-
- Freshman wants to learn.
- And my housemates at my dorm
they wouldn't let me learn.
'Cause it just sounds like
someone's being strangled.
- Well it's so loud.
- [Bonnie] Yeah. Oh, it's terrible.
- Yeah.
- [Bonnie] Really bad.
- But it is beautiful.
- And I was like passing out from,
I didn't have the air to
blow through that thing.
- [Kelly] To sustain.
- [Both] Yeah.
- Yeah, it seems hard.
- [Bonnie] I like it,
- To hold it all and
- [Bonnie] but too hard.
I know it was too hard for me.
I'm glad I stuck with the guitar.
- I think we all are, yeah.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you.
- I think that was a solid decision.